لطالما كان الخلاف والاختلاف عنوان
العريضا لازمات الى الماسك مع الاخرين من
عمالقه السوق التقنيه العالميه اخر
الخلافات كانت بين الى الماسك وبيل جيتس
حول بيع اسهم تسلا حيث وجها ماسك انتقادا
حادا لجيتس بسبب بيعه لاسهم في شركه تسلا
وكان انتقده مسبقا بسبب شرائه سياره بورش
كهربائيه بدلا من شرائه سياره من تسله
وعلى مدى سنوات كانت الازمات والهجوم في
تصاعد بين ماسك ومارك زوربيرج حول مواضيع
متنوعه مثل الذكاء الاصطناعي والصواريخ
نسيم ازمه انفجار صاروخ تابع لسبيس اكس
والتصريحات ماركوس حول خيبته من فشل شركتي
مصر ايضا خلاف ماسك مع ابل ليس جديده
بصناعه الهواتف والاجهزه اللوحيه بانها
تمارس الاحتكار قدام منافسيها وبعد استحوا
به على تويتر بشكل رسمي كان ماسك على موعد
مع خلافات حاده مع موظفي شركه العملاقه
الم يتعرض للفصل التعسفي من قبل الملك
الجديد
طرف تهم العمل بشروطه الجديده